watching the survey side right now we
are flying at 8 000 feet above ground in
the Skies over Leeds scientists are
mapping Britain's energy inefficient
houses with a flying thermometer
all we see are lights in the darkness
but with a thermal camera fixed to an
aircraft they can spot heat escaping
from buildings we'll gain insight into
how people are using the energy that you
know they're being impacted by energy
crisis things that are happening at the
moment the cost of energy and you know
some people are unfortunately not able
to turn on their heating as much and we
may be able to see variations in
temperatures
the clues are in the shades of blue the
lighter the color the more heat is being
lost and in the first flight of its kind
it takes the British company's satellite
view just two hours to map a whole city
yeah the average UK home loses heat
three times faster than a house in
Germany drafty Windows uninsulated roofs
and walls Leaf energy is a massive
problem
29 million properties in the UK need
retrofits to make them fit for the
future the MCS charitable Foundation
funded the aerial survey for the city
council it hopes Stark images will nudge
people into taking action I mean we know
these houses are leaky and we know that
we need to solve that problem we need to
be retrofitting
properties that are at a much much
greater rate than we currently are and
the benefit of this technology is that
it helps us pinpoint all local
authorities in particular to pinpoint
where they really need to channel their
efforts to make the most impact
in North Leeds Jonathan knows all about
the quirks of living in a Victorian
Terrace and we sometimes keep the keys
in just to keep the draft out because
you can feel the air coming through here
all up and down here
the images show he's wasting energy and
money insulation just hasn't been a
priority sometimes your money's got to
go somewhere else you know changing
Windows changing doors isn't that um
keep and sometimes it's some about
getting food on the table it's about all
the other things it's game changing and
now satellite view is about to put its
technology in space from orbiting
satellites they'll be able to measure
heat emissions from any building
anywhere in the world several times a
day giving strategic Clues to activity
in factories and power stations as well
as helping to keep down energy bills
Thomas More Sky News in Leeds